la police new yorkaise a été déployé ici
à times square ce dimanche la raison est
simple des supporters de donald trump
pour déployer un grand drapeau ici
c'était a provoqué la colère d'un
certain nombre de manifestants avec donc
des tensions et la police a été déployée
avec vous voyez pour certains d'entre
eux des casques entier mais tous sont
finalement des images auxquelles nous
sommes habitués aux etats unis puisque
ça fait plusieurs mois que les tensions
subsistent alors certes on n'est pas au
niveau de violences que lors des
manifestations du printemps dernier
après la mort de georges klein mais ici
tout le monde a en mémoire les violents
affrontements entre des manifestants et
des policiers qui semblaient parfois
dépassés
[Applaudissements]
dir
alors pour éviter les scènes de chaos
dans les rues de new york les autorités
ont décidé de prendre les devants dans
une note adressée par la direction à
tous les services de police de la ville
il est demandé à tous les officiers de
se tenir prêt à être déployé en cas de
besoin y compris ceux qui n'ont pas pour
habitude de travailler sur le terrain la
crainte ici c'est la conclusion qui
pourrait régner après l annonce des
résultats dans ce scrutin qui s'annonce
particulièrement indécis toute l'idée
derrière cet entraînement est de séparer
les personnes qui sont là pour créer le
chaos de ceux qui sont là pour
manifester pour une véritable cause cela
fait donc des semaines que les policiers
new yorkais s'entraînent et se forme
pour être davantage opérationnel lors
des manifestations des réunions se
tiennent régulièrement depuis le mois de
juillet est dorénavant tous les
officiers de la ville doit suivre deux
jours de formation concernant des
mesures d'ordre tactique et
psychologique
en conséquence nous devons anticiper et
nous préparer pour des manifestations de
plus en plus grande de plus en plus
fréquentes et de plus en plus intense
jusqu'à l'élection et même jusqu'à
l'année 2021 dans le même temps la nypd
la police new yorkaise a adressé un
courrier aux représentants des
commerçants et des restaurateurs
notamment dans le quartier de milton
manhattan pour leur demander de prendre
des précautions particulières en cette
période délicate
il est notamment demandé à ce qu'ils
peuvent de ne pas trop exposer d'objets
en dehors de leur établissement alors
est-ce que les principaux intéressés
sont inquiets nous sommes allés leur
poser la question il ya eu quelques
manifestations la plupart c'était en
mars avril mai ou encore en juin
il ya aussi encore aujourd'hui mais la
plupart sont très respectueuse nous
n'avons pas eu de grands problèmes et
nous avons la police de new york qui est
la meilleure du monde
donc pour l'instant pas de problème
comme je le dis tout le monde et
respectueux envers notre commerce et
envers les peaux très critiquée par une
partie de l'opinion après ce que
certains ont présentés comme des
dérapages voire des bavures la police
new yorkaise aura sans doute fort à
faire d'ici la fin de l'année 2000
20 on peut imaginer qu'ils espèrent un
résultat sans encombre parce qu'ils
savent qu'au soir du 3 novembre chaque
prise de parole publique pourrait jeter
de l'huile sur le feu et avoir des
conséquences concrètes dans les rues de
la ville